this morning we met with our G7 and NATO  Partners in the margins of this G20  Summit in Bali  we expressed our support and solidarity  with those who suffer from the barbaric  attacks on Ukraine and while we were  meeting in G20 and while we were calling  for the end of the war Russia conducted  massive missile strikes against Ukraine  deliberately Russia is targeting cities  and civilian infrastructure cutting off  children women and men from water  electricity and heating we all condemned  these brutal acts by Russia  and we also discussed the explosion in  Poland near the border we offer our full  support to Poland and assistance with  the ongoing investigation we will remain  in close contact with our partners on  the next steps we will stand with  Ukraine as long as it takes And We Stand  United